ang
que pour quelle Europe es-vous vraiment
et c'est quoi votre choix fondamental
pour l'Europe et qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez c'est plutôt une chance pour nous
ou c'est plutôt un danger avec Schengen
la liération c'est à la fois une chance
et c'est
incontournable la France isolée c'est
une France totalement affaiblie et les
Européens divisés ce sont des Européens
qui ne peuvent pas assumer leur mode de
vie leurs valeurs leur existence dans le
monde de demain j'ai fait campagne pour
mastrich même si je ne trouvais pas que
c'était très bon traité je suis
favorable à la monnaie unique en 1999 au
1er janvier je suis pour
l'approfondissement et l'élargissement
de l'Europe car sans cette Europe il n'y
aura pas de possibilité de survie pour
notre continent
déjà tous les Européens intégrés
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des immigrés
naturels et surtout les clandestins qui
rendent notre vie au quotidien cont tenu
de tous les mots dont on a parlé un peu
parce que même Michel rocker a dit
qu'onit pas cuire la misère du monde
tout le monde dit qu'on contrôle
l'immigration et puis dans beaucoup de
quartiers et ben les gens voient des
immigrés toujour de plus en plus
nombreux alors vous le dites les
socialistes dit tout le monde peu le
dire mais comment s'étonner qui vote à
l'extrême droite effectivement ils ont
l'impression qu'on ne fait rien que les
discours son en décalage avec la réalité
savez je crois qu'il faut voir les
choses dans cette affaire sans
passion mais les Français sont
passionnés je le sais mais il faut
essayer un responsable politique doit
essayer de ne pas avoir de passion la
France est la terre des droits de
l'homme
elle a de ce point de vue une tradition
c'est aussi une terre
d'intégration et donc
elle doit conserver cette
vocation d'autre
part quand on regarde ce que disent les
uns ou les autres on voit qu'il y a en
réalité deux
discours il y a ceux qui disent les
étranger dehors je caricature mais à
peine c'est évidemment
absurde impossible et totalement
contraire pas de nouveau MOS totalement
contraire à ce que j'évoqué à l'instant
comme grande tradition de la France et
puis il y a ceux ce sont les socialistes
qui disent supprimons les lois qui ont
été faites sur le code de la nationalité
sur la protection des frontières et
cetera et donc laissons en fait entrer
tout le
monde naturalisé eu des des des c'est ça
c'est la théorie de Monsieur Jospin
aujourd'hui laissons tout faire tout
aller tout
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a été fait en 81
ça a été effectivement dramatique bien
la France ne doit avoir dans ce domaine
ni complexe ni
faiblesse nous sommes là pour avoir une
vraie politique d'intégration des
étrangers qui sont chez nous et qui
respecte nos lois et qui nous app
machine intégré par il faut et notamment
l'école
mais en revanche nous devons renforcer
nos contrôles à nos frontières ou à cell
de l'ensemble de Schengen de façon à
éviter et à lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine qui est une PL que nous ne
pouvons plus oui mais si on en attrape
un qui est situation irrégulière
qu'est-ce qu'on fait puisquonarrive pas
à le renvoyer chez lui et bien pour le
moment c'est exact nous n'avons pas eu
la volonté politique suffisante pour
mettre en œuvre les procédures que les
lois nous permettent de mettre en œuvre
et trop souvent on a vu la loi bafouer
on a vu la police ou la gendarmerie dans
l'incapacité de la faire appliquer je
sais que ce n'est pas facile notamment
parce que beaucoup d'étrangers
clandestins n'ont plus de papier c'est
nécessaire mais il est nécessaire
d'avoir la volonté politique de le faire